Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism
living this year.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton
and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton bike
in the whole system after I saw my buddy
Kevin Rose, I've known him
forever, some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house
a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him, is it dude? You look great.
What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing
a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean
after like 75 beers and he said,
I've been doing Peloton
five days a week now.
That caught my attention because Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know, I love you Kevin, but
it really peaked my curiosity,
ended up getting a system and it's
become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to
love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually,
but peloton is an indoor cycling bike
that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You don't have to worry about fitting
classes into your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and
this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors
in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors or
find your own favorite
class on demand and in fact,
Kevin and I rarely do live classes
and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun. Kevin,
I'm coming after you,
but we usually just use classes on demand.
I really like not Wilbur's and his iron,
high intensity training
sessions that are shorter,
like 20 minutes and I think
Kevin's favorite is Alex
and everyone seems to have
their favorite instructor or you can
select by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch
HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics.
I think that that along with the realtime
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller
than you would expect so it can fit in
a living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not and
it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is actually special
visit one Peloton that's o n e p e l
o t o n one peloton.com and enter the
code Tim all caps Tim at checkout to
receive $100 off accessories
with your Peloton bike purchase.
You might say Matt accessories.
Wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever
other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and
those are in the accessory category.
So this a hundred dollars
off is a very legit $100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really
entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else or
you just want to get a fantastic gift for
someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com
and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter
the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories including
the shoes that you will want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code Tim,
this episode is brought
to you by 99 designs.
I've used 99 designs for ages since even
before podcasting was a thing and I've
used them for all sorts
of graphic design needs.
They are fast and they are convenience
whether you need a logo, website,
book cover or anything else.
I've done competitions for instance for
book covers related to the four hour
body.
99 designs,
makes great design accessible to
everyone and it makes the process so much
easier.
And I used them recently for artwork
and illustrations inside of my Tao of
Seneca set of books.
So this is a collection of stoic
writing in modern interviews and so on.
So for the Tao of Seneca, I decided to
use their one to one project service.
In this case, you invite a
specific designer to your
project, agree on a price,
and then work together
until you're satisfied.
And the artwork just blew my mind.
Uh,
you have to check it out.
I kid you not.
So you can check out some of
the artwork from Tufts, Seneca,
as well as some artwork and logos and so
on that your fellow listeners have had
made@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim,
that's nine nine designs.com.
Forward Slash Tim,
I really suggest you check it out.
And right now you guys can receive a
free $99 upgrade on your first project.
This gets you, I think,
130% more submissions.
So people who want to work with you and
give you a first drafts of what you're
looking for.
To access your free design,
please visit 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim and click the link on the landing
page.
That's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Today's guest is [inaudible] Phd. Oh
my goodness. Are you in for a treat?
You're going to hear about everything
from monkeys and birthday cakes to
building a personal board
of advisors for yourself.
I'm not going to give you the buyout
right this second because you're going to
hear it from a live recording.
The live recording was taken at sixth
and I very famous historic location in
Washington, DC sixth and i.org.
You can check them out. We're,
I interviewed two different people
in separate sessions. Steve case,
the Co founder of AOL and known for many
other things and then m Sanjin who you
are going to hear from next.
Enjoy.
Everybody loosened up. Limbered all
right, let's just jump right into it.
So this is going to be fun.
I've been looking forward to this,
trying to make this happen, hoping
to make this happen and here we are.
So let me just jump right into it.
Our next guest is m Sanjen Phd,
a global conservation scientist
specializing in how nature preserves and
enhances human life.
He serves as conservation internationals,
chief executive officer.
We haven't met before and we'll get
into that size and joined ca in 2014 as
executive vice president
and senior scientist and his
let several key divisions
divisions. I'm just underscoring
that for you guys including oceans,
science development, brand and
communications and strategic priorities.
That sounds like a lot a Sanjay and
holds a doctorate from the University of
California Santa Cruz and
his peer reviewed scientific
work has been published
in journals including science,
nature and conservation biology.
He is a visiting researcher at Ucla and
they distinguished professor of practice
at Arizona State University,
raised in Southeast Asia in Africa.
Sanjenis background,
the expertise provided a unique
lens for hosting and cohosting,
a range of documentaries for PBS,
BBC discovery and showtime.
Most recently he owes to the University
of California and vox media is climate
lab series.
Sanjayan is a Disney nature ambassador,
a Catto fellow at the Aspen Institute
and a member of the National Geographic
Society Explorers Council.
He puts frequently from his
expeditions at m Sanjen,
that's s a n j. A Y, a n on Twitter.
Please welcome to the stage M.
Sanjay,
welcome.
All right,
so I want to start with something we were
discussing very briefly before we get
up here. And I said, wait, wait, wait.
Don't tell me I want to hear the story,
but let's save it.
What is your full birth name?
Oh No, audio, audio,
mic, microphone check.
Hello. Hello? Hello. There we go.
Okay. Can you guys hear me okay?
Um, first of all, Tim
called me up yesterday
when I was in Botswana
getting on a flight,
22 hours to get here and said,
hey,
you in DC because I'm going to
be there. And I'm like, yeah,
but I'm not just arriving. But that the
end effect, well I'm there for 24 hours,
but hey, I'd love to see you. Do you want
to come to this thing? Oh by the way,
you want to be on stage.
And I'm not very good at saying no,
which we'll get to having listened to
this last podcast about saying no to
things, but I feel so much better today
because I realize it isn't a last minute
invitation cause he did the
same thing to Steve Case.
Really good about it. Okay.
So, um, I'm a towel. Uh,
I'm from Sri Lanka and some of
us are just given one names.
So on my birth certificate
it just says Sanjay,
but my dad's name,
which I use as a last name,
like from my American passport,
um, is Muktar Lincoln.
And I don't use it much for two reasons.
I've actually never one reason to the
obvious one because if someone said Doctor
Lincoln, Lincoln would be my
dad who would look, not me.
So I don't associate it
distinctly with myself.
That's the reason I've told everyone
that reason I don't tend to use it and
never,
ever told this to anyone,
at least not in a public audience,
is that when it came to America,
people have this obsession about what
your name means. They always ask me like,
oh wow, cool man. What
does that mean mean?
Like I don't go around going like Michael,
what does your name mean?
I'm an angel. I get
it. It doesn't come up.
But they do tend to ask that
are foreigners for some reason.
And the problem is this name muck.
The lingam quite literally
means giant pill. Penis.
Okay.
And until I was like a junior,
I was deeply like conscious of
that and I would never say it.
And then one day in a bar somehow it kind
of blurted out and the reaction I got
was relief. And so then it became
not a problem anymore. So the thing
that sounds like a last name meeting, I
would shout from the rooftops, you know,
you know what Lingam is, right? You could,
you guys look it up like Lingam that's
like, you know, a phallic representation.
So it's like penis. It's the same
thing. And with the means Pearl,
it's actually mother of Pearl.
So yeah, that's exactly,
it's like the hope diamond of penises.
It can be from testing last
name ever or did last name.
There we go. So I think the most
logical segue here is to ask you
about bullying during your childhood.
We've suffered many of
us through bullying.
And I want to talk about a monkey,
a monkey who stole your birthday cake.
Can you explain what, what the Hell
is going on here? How did, yeah,
could you please explain
monkey birthday cake story.
I'll do that very quickly because
then it actually comes to one of your
questions that you ask me,
but we just about a strange habit.
So one of my strange habits,
unusual habit is that I
like to do something new.
Something I've never before.
I
like to try it on my birthday.
And that's a tradition.
It's been everything from like writing
portrait or learning how to snowboard
when I was 45 to fly fishing to uh,
learning to bake beef, Wellington,
right? So it could be anything,
but I've never done it before.
And I did this eye institute,
this is a practice about 15 years ago
because I would always get very depressed
on my birthday cause what happened
on my birthday was that very,
there's a long story, I have to do it very
short. So very quick version is no, no,
no quick version. It doesn't have to be
sure. It's all, they're five years old.
We just moved from Sri Lanka to Sierra
Leone, west Africa and not just in town.
We were like in the,
in the bush and the country like
way out there and my mother,
amazingly I get so in Sri Lanka
I was like a little prince.
I had these amazing cakes like you
know, battleship cake, you know,
entire zoo cake.
I mean it was like that kind of cake.
Then we went to Sierra Leone and my
mother and we had to the sort of fleas,
Sri Lanka in the middle of the night, you
know, because of trouble in the country.
And my mom actually packed,
which is amazing.
I think back on it like a pound of flour
and like icing sugar because we came to
Sierra Leon on December 4th and my
birthday was on December 26th and she knew
this and so out there in the middle
of the jungle, she baked me a cake.
It was a simple little round
cake with chocolate frosting,
which is like the simplest frosting
you can. They get right basically.
You can make it almost
anywhere and I didn't like it,
so I was crying as weeping.
I was unhappy about it. My mother
mentioned got tired. She said, you know,
like that's it. I'm, here's
the cake, put it on the table.
She goes in to take a bath and I kind
of stopped crying as you do when you're
five and no one's watching. And I walk
into the living room and are the corner,
my eye catch a glimpse of something.
I turn and look and there's a monkey
and the monkey is holding my cake as a
monkey. Look to me. I look at the monkey,
we're both like the monkeys and then it
jumps and jumps on the window sill in
fleas. It like goes, gone. And I'd
go screening and the cake like, hey,
this, that kind of thing. My mom comes
out, she's like, warrior petrified.
She'd only been the country for a few
days, that point, like 22 days shaking me.
She's like, are you okay? Are you
okay? Like the cake, the cake cake,
she goes to the window,
she goes,
no cake that she goes
to the window and uh,
houses on stilts to avoid flooding
in the, in the rain forest. And,
and she looks down and the cake is down
there and she turns to me and she says,
you wicked wicked child.
Your birthday is cancelled forever.
We will never do birthday again.
Just wait til your father comes home. And
that was it. And now I'm on the floor.
I'm like, because the free child
injustice is like the worst thing ever.
So since then, like birthdays have
been really, really difficult for me.
It's awesome. December 26 was not
great in our for lots of reasons.
And so it creates this gigantic of
anxiety. It's never good enough.
Carry right into adulthood. It was very,
very destructive to everyone around me.
And even today, by the way, too, by the
way, when we get together with my family,
even today, there is discussion about
whether I threw the cake out the window
and the power of story to end.
This is what's happened to my mind.
I start thinking,
did I really see that monkey or did I ask,
I don't even know after a while
with this sort of interesting.
So anyway, that's a very long story, but
that's it. All right, that is a great
story.
I want to hear the monkeys version
of that story at some point.
I'll check that monkey down.
That'll be really awkward podcast.
How did your parents,
or how did your family end up going
to Sierra Leone of all places?
My Dad got a tax in the middle of
the night, you know, my parents are,
the mildest is amicus banded Asians.
You can possibly meet.
My Dad's an accountant and you know,
he never,
like even now when I travel,
no Matt in Botswana or Namibia
or Indonesia or Colorado,
aspen, the same advice. Don't
talk to strangers, be careful
what you eat, you know,
like call. It gets the same kind
of like meek capital advice.
But they had this one
gigantic moment of courage,
which I still don't understand because
even today it would get massive deal to
do,
but these,
these Asians who never have left
the country decided to pick,
pick up the five year old and one year
old and over weekend decide that the
country was getting politically really
bad and with two suitcases and only the
jewelry my mother had just left.
And the only place they,
my dad had a job offer was in Sierra
Leone as an accountant for a forestry
company later on.
His career just took off and he did great,
but it just was this unbelievable thing.
And not just the captain,
not free town like this is like
where Ebola was like recently, right?
I mean this is where there's
a 30th of a warranty early on.
We didn't just go to the capitol.
We went 200 months in the interior and
lived in like a tree house with quite
literally monkeys obviously around us.
And I don't get the, I still ask them then
they're like, yeah, you know, we just,
this is a typical age. Like we
didn't have a choice, you know,
we just get just like the two lotteries
you, when you know the parents you have,
that's one lottery.
You don't get picked that I won that one.
And the country of your birth
is the second lottery. Um,
I sort of snuck into that one,
but those are the two things.
And Steve's completely right. You know,
all of the other things in your life.
10 not to matter as much as
those two lotteries that you get.
So let's talk about the factors or maybe
if you could describe for us how you
ended up in science and then conservation.
Yeah, sure. Um, look, I, you know, I
always love nature. I love animals.
I think all kids love nature
and love things that move.
And as you get older it kind of
gets beaten out of you. Right?
You just get t stop
encouraging to do that.
But my parents just let me do that because
it's the only thing that was sort of
around me.
And I fooled them for a long time
thinking I was pretty mad and kind of went
further and further into that sort of
realm until eventually very late in my
sort of Matt, I had my masters
and just getting into my phd,
I sort of realized that there's actually
a career that was actually open to
Asians.
Um,
in thinking about the environment and
thinking about conservation and thinking
about actually saving the planet that
you could actually do that respectably.
So for most of your life
and be okay with it.
It took a lot of convincing for that
bigger family. Just sort of get that,
you know, once I got my phd,
I tell a story other than my,
you went back to Sri
Lanka and my grandmother,
I overheard her telling her
friend who's like across the wall,
I kind of leans over and they have
this conversation. My grandson is back.
He's a doctor now,
but not the kind of saves people
and by Greg [inaudible]
has yet to add that. Right.
And I started thinking about
it and I'm like, really?
Isn't that what we're
actually trying to do?
Because ultimately it's all connected.
The people need nature to thrive
and that is one virtuous cycle.
But it was a full end game and I bet many,
many people who follow their core
and passion, you know, sort of fuck,
try to find their way to a lot of sort
of fooling around and fooling of other
people, fooling of social circles. I was
just lucky, lucky, lucky enough that,
that there was enough there and I finally
realized that I could actually do this.
What was the triggering event
that you were getting at the time?
So your masters and phd or in
what, sorry? Where were they?
Are the fields with, what was the, what
was the concentration? I mean it was,
you know,
it was biology for my master's and
then wildlife and genetics for my phd.
And was there a conversation or a book
or something that proved to you that
conservation could be a path you could
embrace or was it, you know, honestly I,
I wished there was something
like more epic on that.
I mean I think there were two moments
in my life where I made these big leaps.
Um,
the first was coming to America deciding
that I wanted to be here for like
graduate school or like if I my high
education and that was because of Bruce
Springsteen kid.
You not that's the kid you not,
that's how we picked colleges back then.
Right.
Because you didn't have like I didn't
have like live and have the Internet and I
definitely didn't have any way of knowing
like why America would make sense for
me.
I very little concept of America,
but someone gave me that Nebraska album
and I remember looking at the cover of
that album and something about that cover
and something about the way that the
songs in that and the last song on that
album and it just made you want to think
of sort of endless possibilities
and sort of wide open spaces.
And I always felt confined in my life,
confined by society or by whatever.
I was always a stranger in a strange land.
Well no matter where we move because we
moved around a lot throughout Africa and
sometimes in Asia and I just
felt that that was a big leap,
like taking this sort of
bet to come to America.
And then the second one I think had more
to do with, I had an amazing advisor,
a guy named Michael Sulay who's like the
father of conservation biology. Really.
He coined that word and he put
it on the map. And you know,
20 years ago he was the guy and I
was lucky enough to work with him.
Um,
I just cold called him and sort of pester
them until he took me on as a student.
And I think that made me
realize there was a path there.
So you mentioned this professor,
could you remind me of his last name?
The pronunciation.
Sulay so you leave with that now I've
read that he told you your job as a
graduate student was to train
yourself as a critical thinker.
I believe. Maybe that's the
internet line to me again. But uh,
so what was true was like,
so I was eager to say things like,
you thought that that's what you did in,
you know, I wanted to go save wildlife.
And he said, no. Right?
Right now your job is to just do
a really good piece of science.
It's actually good advice,
like do a really hard piece of work so
that you'd own it and you'd know that
once in your life you could do that.
And there's time enough
later to save things.
He tells me now that he might
not have said that advice today,
but at that time it made an impression
on me. And that's sort of what I did.
Why wouldn't he give that advice
today? Did he explain it? I think he,
I think he is so distraught about what
has happened in the last 20 or 30 years
to our planet. And, and so am I.
And I think we all are really impatient
and I keep waiting for other people to
see something that I have seen in very,
very few people around me somehow
seem to have that gene turned on.
And I think that impatient at what,
what sort of makes us
sometimes be irrational,
but other times just feel desperate.
So the, the intention,
just to take a step back,
so you guys have a better
context here. What are the
no, no, no. What are we doing?
That's the question of the evening.
So I initially I was like, you know,
it'd be really fun is to have Steve Case
come up who's in the book and ask him
questions that aren't in the book.
And then to have someone,
you come up and ask the
questions that are in the book.
But then of course we got the birthday
cake in the monkey and we're off on a
completely different landscape.
So I'm going to bounce around between
questions that I'm dying to ask.
But then the questions that I feel like
it would be fun to sprinkle throughout.
So there's going to be very
little connective tissue.
It's gonna be like the worst
edited movie you've ever seen.
What purchase of $100 or less has most
positively impacted your life in recent
memory?
That's really hard question for me
because I don't buy a lot of stuff.
I'm a total snob when it
comes to like the stuff I own.
And the reason for that is
because I travel incessantly
and when I travel I just
have one bag and I have to take it to
everything I own has to do like double
duty. And so I'm very, very,
very picky about like I the simplifying
or just taking exactly what I like.
So can't think of something really easy
that comes to mind under 100 bucks.
They could just name,
um, icebreaker underwear.
So icebreaker is a great company.
They produce amazing stuff all
at the marina wall and a wall.
You know that New Zealand based company.
I think you and I both know the founder,
um,
and um,
Jeremy Moon and I like his
personal ethos and his stuff works.
I don't get paid by this
company or anything like that,
but that's probably the
last under a hundred dollars
purchase I made that I love.
Do you have a Goto bag?
You mentioned you have one bag.
Have you vetted a lot of bad? Yeah, so
I used to love this Victoria Knox bag.
They don't make it anymore. So the
problem with it's just kills you, right?
Really kills you.
Like you just figure out that this
something that works really well and then
they go and change it. Like
shoes, like athletic shoes.
Oh my God. Did they change it? And
there's a whole race to change it fast.
So this is really a hard
question because um,
I now use it to me bag and I like
it because I liked the four wheels.
I also like the sturdiness of that bag.
It's heavy. That's the
downside on it. All right.
But I'm getting older so I can't really
know everything's on my back anymore.
I need very specific well
wheel to me. Bag. Do you have,
do you have a protocol for surviving or
maintaining your sanity and health for a
really long flights like that flight
from Botswana where I ambushed you with
this invitation. Uh, is there
anything special are you doing?
And I know friends who carry céline Mres
for their noses or wrap their heads and
all sorts of weird contraptions to block
out sound and light or do you just go
out
and you're done? No, you know,
I tried to be like as comfortable as
I possibly can during the flight. Um,
I mean it's just the usual stuff.
I tried to get myself on
the new time zone fast.
I'm very strategic about how when I drink
coffee or anything like coffee or tea,
very strategic about the timing on that.
Um,
I tend to fast a little bit on flights.
I don't eat a lot just because I can
catch up later and it always makes me feel
a little better. I guess that's sort
of it. Like sometimes you get like,
it depends.
It really,
like I did this flight and I'll
be absolutely honest with the,
I fly so much that sometimes I'm flying
in business class, especially very,
very long flight and I have to like
gland there and get into meetings.
Sometimes I find economy,
I did this very long flight from Sydney
to Johannesburg and I'm in the back of
an old seven, four, seven
middle seat with these two.
Very nice but large sum on
gentleman by the side of
the plane hadn't even really taken off.
They both fell asleep and their
hands kept falling into my lap.
I have fifth and I had to like
lift and put it in there like two.
And you know that kind of
flight you just took Kate,
you just have to just completely
do this mind shift. So what you do.
So I stripped all my stuff.
I've got really like into like,
you know like you know my jeans and a
tee shirt, you know, sort of curled up,
made my little space and
then start playing this game.
So all you have to do is think about what
worst form of interpretation you could
be stuck in that moment. So you just
have to think, well this could be, um,
you know, Mombasa too,
you know, like compiler,
you know,
truck driver arrived right now in the,
in the back of like a local bus,
you know, and you'd like, Oh my God,
this will be so much better than that.
Like I can like order food,
they can get drinks and I mean
like you've got just infinitely,
infinitely better, infinitely
better. So that's the trick.
Like I once had to spend an entire
month in a very small cabin on a book,
no windows. It's a research vessel and
stuck in there with another roommate,
tiny for a month and I,
and we had food,
literally cans of food under our bed.
That's how small the whole,
but I kept thinking this is like a
sleeper suite on Singapore Airlines,
like $20,000 ticket right now because
I can sleep, there's a shower.
Like I can walk around and it just
makes you feel so much better.
That's the trick with distance.
Anytime the space constraint,
just think of what's worse and then
just mine shift. It works. No though.
Exit. It sounds like a fantastic trick.
Uh, I'm still thinking about this, the,
the thicks of on hands
learning and their loud.
If you were to be,
we're talking about
your mentors and the advice he gave you.
If,
if you were to have the opportunity
to teach, say give you three options,
a ninth grade class,
college,
freshmen class or college senior class,
you choose one of those three and to
teach a seminar or class of your choosing,
what age would you choose and what
would you teach? You have a semester.
So tell me again how old people are at
ninth grade. Cause I didn't go to school.
It's grades 1514,
15 I would say a 14 program.
I probably teach that
freshman seminar class,
Freshmen College,
freshmen college because I think I
have relatable experiences that I can
translate to that group.
And it's still early enough for that
trajectory to make a big difference.
So that's probably why
I picked that group. Um,
and what would I teach? Yeah. What would
the class be? And it doesn't have to be,
there's no prereq. There's no like
be like, how to get shit done or like
this is a good, this is a
good subject. It's like,
it's like so much stuff that we
learned in college is wasted.
I think he just think about
the vast amount of stuff
that they taught us that we
never ever actually use like that.
So I would love to look.
I would probably teach a class and like
being really honest because I do teach
at university.
So probably would be something
about biology and something
about the environment.
Right? So chances are it'll
be in that thing. It might be,
it might be a class in communication.
So cause I've done like enough television
work and stuff like that to be able to
do that legitimately. So, um, but,
or storytelling, but I would
probably teach a class in biology,
but if I really could get away with it,
I would do something like, you know,
like all of the things you wish you'd
known getting into this or how to organize
your life to get stuff done. You
know, be kind of in that vein.
It's just basically take some of
your books. Cribbet regurgitate it.
So I want to ask both about the
getting shit done. Freshman seminar.
No, no, no. But let, let's just as a
thought exercise, if it were instead,
just so you don't have to think
about the entire semester.
If it were just a three to four hours
seminar and what would be some of the key
principles or strategies or anything
that you would want to hammer home?
Um, you, you're getting me out to a
really long flight. So it's my brand.
Well you can also buy some time by
asking you what you would teach in a
storytelling class.
So none of whites stay with the
or? No, I'm kidding. All right, so,
so the,
what was the question again?
The question was if you have a three to
four hour seminar on getting shit done.
Yeah.
What are some of the,
any of the key messages or strategies
or anything that you would emphasize?
So, um, cause you get a lot done. I mean,
I've observed how much you
do and it boggles my mind.
I don't know how you, yes. So, so the, the
look, you know, there's some,
some of the principles that you'd
probably want to try to get into is um,
you know, dealing with focus,
right? So this is a major challenge,
especially for younger, younger people
and it's not getting any better.
And I have the ability,
right?
And it's not because I have some magical
abilities because he's just practice it
of intensely focusing on one thing for
a few seconds or for a few minutes.
And I think that ability to intensely
focus on something and not be distracted
from anything else,
it's a very useful habit to have.
And so I'm very good at one, like when
you're one on one, you can be one on one.
It can be very focused.
And I think that's true for storytelling.
And that's true for getting
information out of people.
And I think helping people focusing on
one thing and then switching to another.
So it's a series of focus is a
very, very useful practice. Um,
I think that,
you know,
we waste enormous amount
of time pretending to work
and we can just sort of get
rid of that whole thing. I think we, um,
I think we're not honest with ourselves
about what we're really good at and what
we're not good at and in the very early
success to as being absolutely brutally
honest at what you're not good at and
you can compensate for it to some ways,
but just don't like you ask people,
so what do you think you're good at?
And they'll sort of tell you their resume
or they'll recite you. That sort of,
and that's not particularly useful.
Um,
I'll tell them about the
things that I wish I had done.
I think every student that going through
should, should take a class in ethics.
I think every student going through
should take a class on communications and
storytelling.
I think every student who goes through
should think about how during their four
year or three,
whatever their college term is,
spending a little time working on a,
on something that is completely unrelated
to their primary area of interest.
That was probably the best thing I
ever did when I was going through the
American education system is that during
the summers I was restricted on what
jobs I could do because
I was a foreign student.
I would go and work at the World Bank
and for a biologist to be walking around
at the World Bank was a very strange
thing at the time and it was unbelievably
useful to me. It was like the most useful
thing I did. Really. Why was it useful?
Because it just put me in touch with a
whole bunch of people who were completely
unlike me and it was about the world in
a completely different terms and go in
there and be like, you must
be an economist. I'm like,
no, I'm a wildlife biologist.
And they'd be like, wow, that's crazy.
What are you doing here? And, but we,
but I just started realizing how they
worked and how a whole different set of
rules apply and how a whole nother
institution was working on problems,
you know? And just, it just
opened my eyes. It just opened my,
these things would have been for me to
go work for a nonprofit like the one I
work for now, a contribution sash on
the age of consent. He didn't do that.
I really particularly went and got
jobs in areas that had nothing,
nothing to do with my
primary area of interest.
Just to see what it
looked like and the best,
the funnest things in the world
are all on those angles, right?
When you can bring two
different fields together, this,
there's so much gold in those angles.
You do that all the time actually,
and I've really,
you know,
learning how to exploit that is often
your little trick to getting a headstart
and makes me think also of career advice
that I've heard from both Scott Adams,
creator of Dilbert and also
mark Andreessen in different
senses, but they've said
this is more Scott Adams
and his writing that there,
there are different ways
to quote unquote succeed.
One is you can try to be, say top 1% of
1% like a Michael Jordan in one skill.
That's really, really, really,
really difficult of the other approaches
that you could be saying the top 10% in
two typically uncombined areas,
right?
So you have Scott Adams who, who say
himself, he's not the best artist,
he's not the best comedian,
but he's unusually good at
combining both of those things. Uh,
and in the world of business,
it could be say a JD plus
computer science or softer skills.
And I've heard Warren buffet talk
about his best ever investment being,
I believe it was toastmasters or some
equivalent public speaking course,
cause you layer that on top of almost
anything and it automatically puts you in
a position to have a really
unfair advantage. So storytelling,
you were kind enough, we were
trading some notes before this. Uh,
and you mentioned storytelling.
So this is one thing I highlighted
of notes that you sent to me,
which was storytelling is one
way to rule the world. Uh,
and another friend of mine who's
been on the podcast, Chris Saka,
who's just an incredible investor,
hilarious guy,
but the,
he originally trained to be lawyer and
he was beaten soundly at one point by
this guy who got up after Chris had
presented all of his spreadsheets and all
the data and some guy got up, I think it
was in Arkansas or Texas or somewhere,
and he was like, well, you know,
you can't lead a horse to water.
It's something he just started speaking
in like five or six different, uh,
parables and completely
kicked Chris's ass.
And so Chris concluded that story's
beat spreadsheets. Uh, it's,
how have you developed your ability to
tell stories or how would you recommend
people develop perhaps a books,
tools, practices, the ability
to tell better stories?
Because I think it's as, as
you've said, so, so, so powerful.
Right? So I, so I really agree with
what you just said and I think, um,
I think storytelling is one really
powerful way to kind of rule the world.
And a lot of people that we kind of look
up to and think about like, you know,
from Einstein to Elon Musk to um,
Steve jobs,
they were really powerful
storytellers in their own way, right?
So they had this ability through words
or through images to really convince you
that you could do something that no one
else could, could, could think about.
And that just that mind ship that they
created propelled you along with their
vision and all of a sudden you
were doing it. So, and you can,
you can absolutely learn those skills.
You can actually get better at it.
So when I was in high school, I was
painfully shy, like painfully shy,
were very thick glass, had long hair. I
did get the nap all the time. Um, it was,
it was,
I went to school for my high school.
I went to school and it was like
Hogwarts without any of the magic
and he was really a step.
But I had a break and the break was,
this is such a funny brick. So I was
sent to boarding school in England.
This is an England for a year. And the
break was that we had a debate team,
which is quite good and it would go up
against like eaten and all the other
schools like that. And the kid who
was supposed to be like the OT,
the main kid for this debate team,
you know,
got ill and they suggested
that I fill that role.
Um,
and I did and you know,
I really had to the first time
where I did this, you know,
they make fun of my accent
because I had a bit of an accent.
I didn't actually have much of an accent,
but in their minds I had a
very strong Asian accent.
And what I did was I started the
debate with that very, very strong.
I just overemphasized. Everyone
laughed at me. I laughed at myself.
I got over it and I moved on.
That's not a big deal to do today,
but when you're 14 or 15,
it feels big and scary
and really hard to do.
And I realized that there
was power in that by the way.
We went all the way to the finals
and this kid. Then got well,
and then they kicked me off the team.
And then this kid actually lost,
not saying anything here,
but this is exactly what that literally,
I like three debates, three rounds,
like we were, we were doing fine.
The team was doing great. Okay. Um,
he had chicken pox and then he was out
of corn time so you could come back on
the team and then I was
off. Um, okay. So you can't,
you can't practice.
You can get better.
So I practice and I think about it and
I think about how people tell stories.
I even Tim, like you've looked at Tim's,
what you open that first couple of pages,
he talks to that little story that he puts
in there about, you know, you, you know,
what he was grappling with in his
college days immediately captivates.
You just immediately want to
know more and read more, right?
So there's real power there. Um, and
you can develop and get better at it.
So what are some of the ways
in which you can do this?
So you have to be genuinely interested
in the stories you're telling.
You can't fake that.
Like if you're interviewing someone,
you've got to be actually
a fan of that person.
Even if you're not a fan of
that topic or that person,
or not genuinely interested,
it's just not gonna work, right?
You got to own that story. It's gotta
be all, you can't bluff the story.
It can't kind of lie about it.
You can learn a story and
repeat someone else's story,
but you really have to own it in
like a deep, deep sense of it.
Um, you have to know when to stop. Uh,
you have to know when to, you know,
the messengers are so important, right?
So there's something I often
say it is not just the story,
but it's also the kind of stories you
tell and they have to be true to who you
are as a, as a storyteller. So look this,
I'm not a professional
like teaching people
how to tell stories. I can't do that
professionally. I know I do it in my,
I practice it,
I got it from my parents.
I think it's a wonderful
craft to think about,
read books and read books and figure out
what piece of that is really catching
your heart.
It always starts with the heart.
It always come from place of
commonality and laughter and love or,
or pain or something from the heart
before you can engage the mind.
And that those sorts of
stories always tend to win.
So want to underscore something you
said then I want to ask about this very,
very,
uh,
clear smirk that came on your face when
you just said something a second ago.
But,
uh,
I think the going for the
heart or noticing what
captures the heart applies to
questions too. So, uh, for instance,
a cal Fussman who was one
of the main writers of the,
what I learned column and Esquire
for a long, long, long time,
I want to say 10 plus years interviewed
Gorbachev and all these people routinely
would get told right before an interview.
Yeah, this hour long interview,
you now have five minutes.
And so you would have to hook someone
like Gorbey into continuing to talk and
you'd think about his questions.
And then he'd say, you know,
tell me about when your father left for
war and was there any particular lesson
he taught you?
And he would go for the emotion first
and that would then allow him to get to
the headier questions
later. So I think that, uh,
it applies to not only the telling
of stories, but the asking,
the eliciting of stories and
good storytelling is that
right? So in a good story,
a really phenomenal story is one way you
actually are having this relationship
with their audience.
And it's a two way story when
p and people do that magically,
you're at a whole nother
kind of level of it.
And like when you talk about how you
organize your questions, you know,
it sounds so simple, like, okay,
he's got a bunch of questions that there's
so much thought going into it because
you're actually engaging a story.
You're doing it in that way so that you
can get the whole thing kind of coming
out. Right? Yeah,
absolutely. And, uh, the,
the piece that I wanted to ask about it,
and maybe it was just because you
enjoy smiling and do it so well,
but you said you have to know when to
stop and then you may thing yet this big
grin on your face. Maybe that was just
me noticing something that wasn't there,
but what's,
what's behind knowing when to
stop or like what's the opposite?
What does that look like? Just telling
a long story that goes on too long.
The best storytellers leave you wanting
to hear more best comedians just
absolutely we leave you wanting to
hear more. There's a real art to that.
You can't give it all away.
You have to leave the audience saying,
I wanted to hear like tell me more.
Like,
and that's really important about knowing
when to be able to stop and you can
always explain things
many, many ways. And I'm,
I'm really not particularly today by
the ways and then in my apologizing a
little bit for that. But that's
a really important skill to know.
Like when does that story end?
Don't bury the punchline,
you know, like, you know,
like so many times it's like there's a
whole windup where I'm going to tell you
now a story about a monkey
that stole Mike. Don't do
that. Just go right into it.
Like, cause you have them at the first
minute and then at every minute after that
you're going to start
losing audience shares.
So you want to get it fast and get
right into, into it as fast as you can.
So I want to talk about, uh, by the way,
can I tell you one thing about that?
Because I just think yes,
of course. So, you know,
when I was talking about the message and
the message about owning your story, go,
go do this. When you get a
chance, when you get home,
you know that song respect re res Pct,
you know that song, right? Yeah. So
who sang that? Right at the Franklin?
Everyone knows who read the fine grain
or everyone can like Hammad right now if
I played it to, you know, in a heartbeat,
but she's not the one who's
actually first sang it.
It's actually done by Otis Redding.
Same words, same song, very different.
Meaning the song is really like
exact opposite of where they are.
Either makes that song to be
Otis Redding Song. It's like,
you know,
I'm working all day woman and I'm like
putting food on the table for you.
And like when I fucking come
home, I'm so sorry. I said Duh.
When I come home all I want is just
like some goddamn respect. Right.
That's his song. Never made it big. But
all his writing was a big singer by then.
A decent song, decent
blue songs. She owned it.
She complete same words but just
the way she put that story together,
her complete ownership of it and who will
forget her spelling of that just makes
her like mix of the one who
remembers it and later on in life,
Otis actually sort of kind of
complaints slightly about about her,
like taking the song and making it
so huge and no one remembers that.
He's the one who recorded it and sang it
and performed it for at least two years
before she came along. So just you
want to hear, seek two stories,
same story, told in different ways.
Listen to those two songs. That's amazing.
I had no idea.
I want to talk about some of the stories
and the stories may not be the right
word,
but narratives that have stuck with you.
And I'm going to prompt with a question
and I can certainly cheat a little bit
in prompt,
but what is the book or books you've
given the most as a gift and why,
or books that have
influenced you? Yeah, we,
Tim and I have talked about
this a little bit. So for me,
books are like all about the moment in
the motion that I'm in and the person I'm
giving it to.
It is an,
and so I can't tell you that there's one
book that has predominated how I give,
because I love books and I love to
give books and I carry books around.
And even today I brought two books for
you to autograph that I'm giving away.
Right?
So there's an act of giving and that,
and that in a book is a wonderful way
to convey something to another person.
Um, books that I've loved giving away. Um,
Norman Maclean's river runs through it.
I read that book in so many
different ways and so many pieces.
It totally influenced my life in terms
of fly fishing and finding sort of magic
and words,
that quiet space.
You also wrote that book
when he was 71 years old.
Kind of really the only
big book he wrote said 71.
And you think about all this bullshit
about like creative genius being in the
young and all of that.
As you get older you start appreciating
that if Norman could do it at 71,
maybe I could do it like, you
know, not quite at 71 yet. Um,
another book I really liked,
um,
more recent book is Stanley
Mcchrystal's team of teams.
Completely different reason.
Just a really clever,
smart book about how to
organize businesses and
enterprises for today's world.
And he takes us in sort of
experience from the army and in, in,
in Afghanistan and sort of,
you know,
and brings it over to sort of to your
life or my life and makes it kind of
relevant and meaningful. I found
it very influential. Um, I,
I've given away a quite a few
copies of James Nester's book,
the deep joy. You might have read,
write, read his, haven't read the deer.
That book is pretty damn good.
It's about, it's about free diving.
I knew nothing about and that was,
that was one of my birthday things.
That was like two years ago.
So I thought I'd tried the spray down in
him because I read an estrous book and
it's amazing the physiology of the human
body and what it can do is amazing.
So I read this book,
it's about free diving and very scary,
very sort of can be very dangerous sport,
but also an amazing sport because it
completely changes the way you think about
your body and what you're capable of.
And I thought, what, right this is,
this book inspired me. I'm going to
go try and take a lesson in freedom.
So went to Hawaii around my birthday and
I took a lesson from a very, very good,
you want to do this with someone
very, very good. And I did.
And this woman's Shelly Eisenberg, who
was my teacher for the day, you know,
basically, look, this is what
she did. Within three hours,
I can hold my breath for like
maybe 45 seconds, maybe a minute.
I tried within three hours,
three hours just by doing exercises
with me. She had me at two minutes,
10 seconds.
That floored me.
It'd be like saying how fast can
you run it and be like, okay,
I can do like a nine minute mile.
And you saying,
well give me three hours and I
get you down to like a six minute.
Like he just couldn't do that and that.
And she's like,
yeah, like let's keep going. And
like sure enough, you know, the new,
you're doing three minutes,
three minutes within
24 hours under yeoman.
True story can do it.
Everyone in here can do that too.
That's why that book was
so kind of mentally be
transformative.
I feel obligated as the person who,
certainly not a doctor,
and you've heard this before,
I don't play one on the Internet,
but you have to be very, very careful
with this type of training. Uh,
so do not do take the DIY
approach. Uh, I know people,
I know people who have died and I know
people who have come very close to dying
from shallow water blackouts. And
when you, depending on the technique,
if you blow off a lot of CO2,
you won't sense that you're going
to black out before you blackout.
You're fine and then you're blacked out.
But you don't really want to have
happen in any amount of water. Right.
You could Jimi Hendrix herself or it
could be in a thousand feet of water,
same outcome. So be very, very
careful only with supervision.
But it is fascinating.
Yeah.
I mean two navy seals drowned
in a training exercise in
San Diego like two years
ago.
Yeah.
Just the two of them just trying this
out and breaking the rules of that.
The number one thing with this is just
like you're doing it with a buddy who can
do this better than you can and,
and,
and she goes and you
definitely want to do this.
And that's why I didn't just
try this. Yeah. I read his book.
Then I went and got like one of the
best teachers and I spent time with her.
And that's why I think it's
thanks billboards. Let's talk about them.
If you could have a giant billboard
anywhere with anything on it,
Bill Billboard with a message you would
get out to millions or billions of
people,
what would it say and why?
Um, I'm going to take an
easy one out, but yeah,
I'm going to use one of the slogans that
we at conservation international use in
some ways,
which I would probably say something like,
either people need nature
that's not obvious enough.
I'd say nature speaking,
I might say nature screaming and I'd like
to put those outside every place where
there's like this quote
unquote natural disaster,
which is usually a human disaster that
was exacerbated by just not listening to
nature. Um, that's what I do. And
I'd always influenced by like,
you drive across this country,
you see these signs for like
religious purposes, right?
Like so, so, and so daddy will do
this to you or not do this to you,
only you believe. And I was taught, well,
why don't we put that same kind of effort
into putting billboards up that says
nature screaming or nature speaking,
when are we going to listen
to something like that?
So that's probably what I done it.
I really want to, and this isn't
just a professional courtesy,
so we can talk about the work
you're doing. Conservation and uh,
the,
the state of progressive
destruction of our
natural habitats and surroundings
causes me a lot of anxiety. Uh,
personally. Uh, in part because
I feel like for instance,
if a study comes out on metabolism
and there are a bunch of conflicting
headlines and things are
poorly interpreted by certain
media, I can parse it.
I can go to pub med,
I can figure out what's what.
But in the world of a conservation
are trying to do the right thing,
I sometimes feel lost in the sense that
I attempt to do the right thing when I
perceived to be the right thing.
And then I find out, oh shit,
that type of wild caught fish or farmed
is exactly the opposite of what I should
be doing or whatever it might be.
B a
what are,
you're gonna have a lot of people
listening to this, people in this room,
then people on the podcast.
What are some of,
if people want to think more precisely
about this and feel like they can take
proactive steps,
what are some of the most common
misconceptions about conservation?
Or what's a smart way to just approach it?
Thinking about it?
Right.
So the first thing I would say is don't
let perfection and trying to find the
silver bullet keep you out of the game.
So we were both recently, um, at a,
at summit in Los Angeles and you know,
I heard people talk about philanthropy
and giving and wanting to find like the
most perfect way to get,
and I was sorta struck by how many
people were around me all nodding.
And I used to think to myself
like really like, yeah, okay,
I want to make sure my dollar
goes the furthest as well.
There's so many other things in life,
which we waste all the time.
And why this one? We want
perfection. So you know,
when you, when I, when
someone says to me like,
tell me the one thing I can do to change
the planet. Like, guess what, there isn't,
there's lots of things and it's messy.
You're not always going to get a right.
And is it better to drink out of ceramic
cup that you have to wash in hot water
or uh, you know, a Styrofoam Cup.
Those are important questions
for you to think about,
but ultimately they shouldn't stop
you from, from getting engaged.
So the truth of the matter is very,
very,
very few people are actually engaged in
like trying to care about the fate of
our planet, fate of where we
live and our kids lives. Um,
and I just want to get more people in it.
And I think if more in it,
then absolutely we'll come
up with more honed solutions.
But it shouldn't stop you from getting
in it. So that's like my first thing.
I would say if you want to make
some small changes in your life,
like what you eat and how you cook,
it makes a huge difference.
Like it's probably the one thing that
you could do to being thoughtful,
like whether it's farm
caught or wa that's it.
Useful question to think about and try
to get least the best pathway there.
And I can answer that for you.
Like you like seafood watch and
the Monterey Bay aquarium puts out,
gives you a reasonable pathway,
but how you cook and how you waste food,
like wasting food is a big, big deal.
Like your energy output on those,
it's like completely outweighs what car
you drive or anything like that. Right?
So that's just something
simple you can do, you know,
get engaged in the political
system. I think it really
does matter. I, I, you know,
I mean it really does matter,
right?
So there was this kind of crazy
decision very recently on,
on wanting to at this moment in time,
but all of these crises
are going on the planet on,
on overturning the ban on
importing elephant heads from,
from trophy hunting from Zimbabwe and
Zambia like that actually somehow became a
priority for the administration. Like all
of a sudden like we're gonna like, oh,
turn the bands so that any hunter who
goes to Zimbabwe or Zambian shoots an
elephant and bring the ivory and
they had into the country. Like,
why is that all of a
sudden the thing to do?
And people really got upset about it
and believe it or not kind of did change
something. At least for now, there's
been a reversal of that decision.
So the administration has decided to like,
wait on that for a while.
So make your voices heard.
It's important that you make your
voices heard and don't sit this out.
Are there any other resources that
you would suggest people look to?
Like Seafood Watch or
uh,
any other websites where people could
find simple things they might not think of
like this lower shipping,
uh,
to make an impact.
I mean,
if just assuming these people are busy
professionals with high demands on their
time,
would you suggest they look okay?
So now and without being
totally self serving.
So I will say my own organization,
conservation.org decent website.
You'll find lots of ways in which you
can be engaged. The Nature Conservancy,
nature.org decent website,
lots of ways you can get engaged
in environmental defense fund.
They do a lot of great work, particularly
in the United States around climate. Um,
world resource institute gives you the
macro picture. They've great graphics,
great infographics, gives you
sort of the macro picture. Um,
I did a series recently on vox vox with
the University of California called
climate labs,
which are just these eight minute
very short digestible little videos on
something like food waste,
slightly irreverent,
slightly counter intuitive,
simple ways in which you can either get
engaged or make the change in your life.
You can have an impact.
And so we took a bunch of
different topics like shipping and,
and did the short videos on,
it's called climate labs on box.
So those are sort of things
that come quickly to mind.
But here's the most important thing.
Seriously, I really mean this.
We really are on a race to save the
planet. I really, really believe this.
W you know,
here's the thing,
we're the only generation who
actually has some foresight.
I think that this and the
entire history of humanity,
we had to like rely on like crystal balls
and like, you know, like, I don't know,
like a burning Bush,
right?
Sitting where we are,
give us a glimpse to give us a
glimpse of where we're heading.
And now we actually some big with the
first generation in human history to see
the INTAPP Emmett John Glenn,
before he passed away,
amazing guy makes America just
American to go round planet.
See the whole thing I asked him,
he said he had blew me away.
I never thought we could see
the whole planet all at once.
Like if you were standing on a flat earth,
if you're standing on, on uh, on the,
on the seashore, you see about seven
miles after that, the horizon dips away.
And as long as humans have been around,
we've been climbing taller
and taller mountains, towers,
trees to be able to see what's over
the horizon, what are we looking for?
We're thinking about Elian that's over
the horizon and my buyers are looking for
opportunity now in our generation we
can see the whole thing and only that we
also mostly all connected.
There is no reason for us not
to act right now and believe me,
that window is small
and if we don't do it,
I swear future generation will
look back and said, what a waste.
You had that opportunity when the
opportunity costs was actually relatively
cheap. The price of conservation
will never get cheaper in the future.
It's as cheap as it's going to get now,
only get more expensive.
So not acting now is crazy and that's
what people who've done the giving pledge,
like Cakes d case and others.
I so applaud that because they're not
just saying we're going to lead this.
We would,
you know,
leave this for future generations to deal
with this and we're going to deal with
it now because right now it's probably
the cheapest to be able to deal with it.
[inaudible]
so I'll ask just a few more questions
and then we'll do some audience and then
we'll head off to Tequila
shots or whatever comes next.
But I really want to ask you what you
found helpful for training humans to think
more long term.
Because it strikes me that if you look
at history and you don't have to go very
far back, but you certainly
could, that we've a mall,
we've evolved for millions of years
effectively to survive until puberty have
sacks and procreate. Yeah.
That's basically, yeah.
I mean that's Darwinism at work and
people will act in their,
in intensely,
uh,
I mean, worst of interests, long
term for short term gain. Yeah.
How do you train people to think more, uh,
in long,
longer term time horizons and in ways
that are more communal and not individual?
It's, it seems like a very tough task,
but a very, very, very important one.
What does it,
what are some of the,
okay,
most effective learnings or
lessons that you've had with that?
I, I'm, I don't know. That's
the truth of the answer.
I don't know how to fundamentally
evolutionary biology.
It is so hardwired into us,
the people who do and do it rationally.
So you'd like look at like, you know what
Charlie Munger says, right? It says, look,
we basically, our investment
technology technique, you know,
that he and buffered use is just don't
do anything stupid over the long run.
Pretty much that that's, he
basically says that, right? It's,
it's surprisingly simple,
but incredibly hard to follow,
incredibly hard to follow.
And the people who do it tend to be
sort of investors and others who, who,
who sort of faithfully follow a system.
But even they get spooked as we, as
we've seen many, many times over. Right?
So it's very difficult to beat it.
So I'm not trying to do that.
I'm just trying to figure out how I
can make you changing your life for the
betterment of the planet in your
own enlightened self interest.
And the better I can do that and tell
you that it's actually gonna make your
life better now. Now, now, now,
not even your kids, but your life,
the better chance I have
of promoting change.
The interesting thing is it doesn't have
to be rational because we do so many
things that are completely irrational
and so it doesn't have to be rational.
It,
it can be very emotional and it has
to be about your own enlightened self
interest.
It can't be about the future.
So I think at some point we'll have to
do around too. But look, that's just my,
like I'm stuck and any help you
have and want to throw it my way.
Wowway we'll,
we'll take it,
but I'm actually stuck because I know
much better communicator than I am and far
smarter people than I am in my field was,
we're basically stuck as well.
Well too.
To that point with them.
I know my next question is going to
be what ask would you have of people
listening,
is there anything that you're looking for,
any particular type of help or just next
steps that people you would like to see
people take? Because you have to
have a lot of people listening,
people in all different walks of life,
different sectors,
every possible place imaginable. What
would you like them to do or consider?
So,
um,
the most important thing you could do
for me or for us or for this cause is to
be a messenger.
It really is quite simply that because
the people who are more likely to listen
or people like yourself,
the more likely it is that message
coming from you than if it came from me.
And that's really like,
so I strongly believe like I
strongly believe in that, right?
It's the messenger matters as much as
the master and you can reach audiences
that I could never reach.
So being that messenger to carry
that message into your community,
into your church or synagogue,
your place of worship, your school,
your community,
your family is far,
far more useful than me trying to just
get my voice to be bigger and bigger and
bigger. Thank you. Uh,
and where can people say
hello to you on social or learn
more about what you're up to?
Is Twitter the best place? I'm sorry.
Is Twitter the best place for him?
Twitter is a good place.
Um,
Facebook is also really good because
it allows a longer conversation to just
sort of occur. So you know, I'm,
I can easily be found as m Sanjayan and
some on Facebook and that's a good place
to also engage in trade is fine too.
Then conservation.org yeah,
and conservation.org. So I, you know,
I think our website and our social media
platform is a great place to engage.
Perfect.
So we'll take me for a DC audience,
but I think also for our global audience.
Okay.
So this is, this is, I think a good
place to grab. Just a few questions,
then we can,
we can close up and have some,
have some Tequila. Give George Clooney
a few hundred million more dollars.
February as a customer.
You go story. What us.
All right. By the way, while
he's thinking about that, I,
one of the book I want to mention to
you guys, especially for this town,
is a book called down destiny of
the republic by Candace Maillard.
It's a fantastic book.
She's a great author and she talks about
President Garfield and being shot and
how his life could have been saved if
they'd only listened to the surgeon who
gave them the advice.
But he was sort of ignored because it
was this black surgeon in the union army.
And instead they took another route.
And it's just been a fascinating story
about race and technology at the cusp of,
of a really important
moment in our nation.
But a president that very few
people had heard about, but who,
if he had survived with completely
changed the course of our country,
probably for the better.
So this,
this is a question from bill long island.
Uh, it's addressed to me,
but I'm going to ask you,
since I've talked at nauseum
about my mornings, uh,
what does the first 60 to 90
seconds of your day look like?
I'm going to modify this, uh,
but, but he's asking what,
what to do to jump start
the first waking moments.
Do you have any morning rituals or
routines that are consistent for you?
Okay.
Uh, anything that you do in
the first coffee? Yeah. Uh,
to jumpstart my day?
Yeah.
Or just anything that you do as part of
your routine in the mornings. Yeah. So,
you know,
I often put like the toughest things I
need to deal with and the most creative
things early in the morning.
It's just as simple as that. Um,
I tend not to,
um,
I tend not to check my email
until I'm actually starting work.
That's just something I, my, my work
email on until I'm actually starting.
What is it just really quiet as the mine
and what, so what happens with email is,
especially for my company because
it's a global organization,
so I get emails in the middle of the night
and so they pile up and see if I find
out that if I,
if I open my day by checking email,
I get diverted into all these other small
things that I am very bad at saying no
to. So I kind of ruined the
rest of that day and raw the,
I sort of want to set my agenda then
look at it and deal with the ones I can
deal with and ignore the others.
This is a question from, it's either
Eric or Erin, I'm not quite sure. Uh,
who's your most recent mentor and
what has that person taught you?
And I mean we could make that if
you have an answer for that. Great.
Otherwise we could,
we could modify it to just be what is
a recent lesson that you've learned or
insight.
So you know,
that's a good one because it kind of
Hawk Hawk of the back to you know, tribe,
tribal mentor. So one of the things
that I did that I found very,
very useful in my life and I think for
many of you you could apply to is that
some years ago I created a personal board,
so a group of individuals who would
personally spend a little bit of time
investing in me and my success,
and I didn't do this because it's some
grandiose notion of why was it struck me
that whenever you wanted like letters
of reference, when you go for a job,
you're always didn't have to like sort
of scramble around and try to catch up to
people who you haven't spoken to for a
long time and hope they'll give you this
letter and they really don't know you
by that point in life is sort of gone by
and they'll,
well,
what happens if I had a group of say
five individuals that I would pick and I
would make a promise that I've never
solicited them for money, which I've,
I've kept up in, there's some now do
give to Cei, but that's not the purpose.
They don't belong to my organization.
They're not my board for my organization.
There my personal board,
um, and the great people and I
would just say to them, listen,
can you do this for me? I'll meet with
you two, maybe three times a week.
We'll have coffee or lunch
two, three times a week, sorry,
two or three times a year.
Okay, I got it. I was like, man,
this is a really generous for us.
Sorry. Um, and we'll, you know,
we'll just have a little conversation and,
and a catch up and I can just
occasionally ping you for guidance.
That has been incredibly, incredibly
useful. I picked some great people.
Um, you might know some of them,
but it's been very, very helpful.
Okay. So I want to, I want to dig into
this because this is really interesting.
So your personal board, by
the way, they all said yes.
One person tell me down. Well, yeah,
how can we not get into this? Uh,
now I want to mention just as a side note,
because people might find this helpful.
Something that I've found very
helpful from Chris Fussell who,
uh,
coauthored a team of teams with
Stan Mcchrystal and he was,
uh, stands aide to camp for quite
a long time and Jay sock, uh,
and advice that he was
given was at all times.
You want to surround yourself
with at least three people,
someone who is doing an excellent
job of what you hope to be doing,
say a few years from now,
someone who is doing a better job than
you are in some capacity at what you're
doing now. And then somebody who
is doing something you used to do,
but it's doing it much
better than you did.
And that was how he ended up
seeking people to surround himself
with. How did you choose
since they all said yes,
I guess you reached out to
five or six people, right?
Or how did you choose those people?
What were the criteria?
You know, I look, I wanted
people I, I respected.
So that was sort of important to me.
They had to be people I
really sort of respected.
I wanted people who were not in my field
because I had plenty of colleagues in
my field. Um, I wanted people, so
it was, I'll just give you some,
I'll give you some names.
I don't think it matters that much.
So Tom Tierney Bridgespan, he's also the
chairman of the Nature Conservancy now.
Really Smart Guy. You know, he kind of
gets how businesses should organize.
He sort of just this,
he coached me on how to get the CEO job
for conservation international and the
tips he gave me what incredibly valuable,
like incredible.
I'd never realized that you could
actually coat your way into a job.
And that guy really helped me do
that. So that was one. Paula Kerger,
she's the see the president
of PBS mazing woman.
Very unusual.
She was a development staff.
She asked people for money and then
rose up the ranks and ended up running.
PBS should also is across
the road from my office.
So it's kind of easy to sometimes see
her really smart, very thoughtful,
wonderful kind,
generous person gaining set.
Neimann crosspoint venture partners. It's
one as companies also race car driver,
that guy interview CEO's for lending.
So his whole job is about interviewing
CEO's and deciding which ones he wants to
bet on. As a, as a venture capital guy,
really useful for me as I'm thinking
about what qualities and attributes I want
to strengthen, you know, as a CEO.
So I sort of looked at it that way as
I created this group of folks who could
sort of help and guide.
Were they people that you'd had
contact with before or yeah, no, no.
They were all people who had somehow
been in my orbit. And then I thought,
well let's just try and make this formal
in some way and let's just see if they
would agree to do this. And they all said,
yeah, and one or two of those. But yes,
so long as you do that to me in return,
which was a very nice flattering thing. I,
I'm sure it doesn't work that way,
but that's been very useful. And,
and believe me, I did end up using
that board when I went through my seat,
the CEO search.
So it was 150 days ago,
our founder who had been
running contribution to
Nashville for 30 years step
down and you know,
and I became the CEO and last year the
board went through a very challenging
process of trying to decide who the next
CEO and what the next leadership team
would look like.
And it's a very scary moment for an
organization because all the half of the
CEOs who come in after found a fail.
And actually if you want to get the job,
you want to be the one in waiting.
Like seriously.
Like that's what typically happens.
New CEO comes in,
they fail and either the old CEO comes
back or the person in waiting kind of
gets the role and then runs it.
So it's fraught with challenges
and dangers all over the place.
And I really didn't think I would get it.
I thought there was a
chance I would get it,
but I was really worried
about it for lots of reasons,
including my color to be
absolutely honest. Um, and this,
these groups of this mentoring group,
honest to God, coached me, them.
And a couple of other people really
helped coach me through this.
Can you share any of the advice?
Yeah, one of the good simple one.
So this is such an amazing thing and
I've applied for other jobs before,
like kind of like the CEO or top level
person job and not got that three times
in the past. I've been rejected
for that. Get very close.
And then somehow either they talked
me out of it, I get rejected,
here's what I was doing. So they
would ask me. So do you like,
tell me about the social, why
do you want the job? Well look,
I've got a good career. I don't
really need this. But you know,
if it was the right thing,
you know,
you kind of had this like kind of a
long meandering story about saying,
you know, I'm not totally vested.
Like yeah, I could do this,
but I could do a lot of other things.
And I actually feel that
way in a lot of ways. Right?
So in a lot of ways I think I'm
definitely, I didn't start my life again.
I want to be the CEO of
Conservation International.
There was never a dream is never a goal,
never got the goal was much.
It goes to have impact and
really care how I had impact,
but with these guys said to me was like,
one guy actually said this to him.
He said, that is not the right
answer. I want you to repeat after me.
Say I will walk through a
wall to get this job. He said,
I'll say it like my radio set
side. I walked through. It says,
now when you go into an interview,
they're going to ask you this question
and I want you to repeat this.
I will walk through. He did. First
question, why do you want this job?
Tell us what prepared you for this job.
I said, let me make one thing clear.
I will walk through a wall together
and they all went great
because guess what? Most times
when you're hiring people,
and I do this all the time,
I hire people all the time
and I'm so amazed that I
didn't listen to my own rule.
You want someone who gives
you the confidence that
they will solve the problems
that you don't want to deal with.
You want someone who's coming in and say,
you know what? I got this. You don't
want someone to come in and say,
I don't know if I really wanted to
convince me it start negotiating day one.
Don't want to do that. It's
a very, very simple rule.
So whatever job you go for,
start by saying, let me be clear.
I really want the swack job.
I will walk through a wall to get the job.
Now let me tell you what makes me
so great for this and slay it out.
You can negotiate later.
Really some point
when you sent the emails out to recruit
this x men team of mentors to formal
structure. Well, a couple of questions
and this won't go on and on for hours.
Don't worry guys, even though it could
and it might later with Tequila. Uh,
I don't know why I keep
thinking of Tequila. We could
psychoanalyze that later.
Uh, do you interact with these
mentors as a group or is it all
one, two, one, one on one?
All that they know about on one because
getting them together as a group would
be too impossible. Yeah. Do
you block out say a week?
Every quarter just to schedule them
in in batches? Yeah, and I did not.
I schedule it around travel
that I have unnecessary.
So I do this as much as I can in person
unless I have a crisis or an emergency
and just need to get on the phone and
then they're always willing. Like I,
I literally,
today I had a little 90 crazy,
I literally had a CEO of a company,
I didn't want to name it,
but normally nor was enormous company he
would turn to my call today is so slow.
It's like, I'm so sorry it took me so
long to get back to you. And I'm like,
are you kidding me? And
he's like, they, you know,
once you get that relationship with
that few individuals, it, it does work.
It can really work very well.
Did you make, did you say, Hey,
let's grab coffee and then make the
pitch in person or did you lay it out in
email made it either? No, I did.
I don't think I did by email.
I think I did all by phone or when I
met them in person after back the first
coffee. So the people I knew, well
I did by phone and the Pea by,
I'll tell you one thing though,
I do take it so seriously.
So when I go to see them are two
things that I never make informal.
Like two things that I
never make informal. One is
when I talked to my board,
my organization board or
my group of mentors board,
which means I put on a
shirt, I kind of, you know,
I put on a jacket if it's appropriate,
I just, whatever way you want to do it,
and it's not about dress code,
but whatever you want to do it,
you want to make sure they understand
that you are using and taking their hour
really seriously. So just don't waste
time with that. The other thing I do,
I always take seriously
when I ask people for money,
something that I never do kind of on the,
I will never ask someone for a donation
or to fund conservation and tasks or
when I'm having a drink with them or
when I'm like fly fishing with them or
going on a hike with them because people
don't want to be hit up all the time
the same and I think you want to go do
that and like enjoy it and have fun and
then you want to say,
can I meet with you at three o'clock
tomorrow afternoon or can I meet with you
at 8:00 AM 8:00 AM tomorrow
today? Whatever it is you
want to like just clean up,
show up and be straight about it.
It's,
it lasts like two questions,
20 questions again,
but when you're preparing for
one of these meetings, yeah.
What does it look like?
I mean you're trying to make you have
60 minutes with such and such super hot
shot.
What's the format of the hour?
It often depends.
At this point?
It depends on what the major thing that
I'm dealing with as it has been and
what's been kind of bugging
me on my mind that I really,
could you give an example or is it
too personal? I mean, look good. Look,
there's no, it is not a big surprise.
Anytime a founder leaves an organization,
there are, there's the, Oh, so
here's a really legitimate answer.
So I was not the only internal
candidate going for this job.
There were two other very,
very good candidates for this job as well,
and they both could do this job.
It both could be CEOs.
And my number one task as soon as I
knew I was going to get this job was to
figure out a way to keep them.
The almost never happens,
and I think what you've just done,
you've now lost the second best
person to run your organization,
just walk out your door.
It almost never happens.
So that was something I prepared for. I
thought about how I might try to project.
I went to them and I said, this
is a problem. It's a big problem.
Tell me what I need to do to be able
to do this. And they gave me some of,
not all of them, I mean different people.
And you've got to pick and choose.
You know, you've got to filter
that advice. But the two
individuals, I went to, Amy,
incredibly good advice that I followed
to a t and it's served me well because I
think it's every Malbec get both those
individuals are incredibly valuable and,
and still part of
contribution. Well, all that.
Thank
you so much.
Good advice ladies.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one.
This is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of
fun before the weekend?
Five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and
you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought
to you by 99 designs.
I've used 99 designs for ages since even
before podcasting was a thing and I've
used them for all sorts
of graphic design needs.
They're fast and they are convenience,
whether you need a logo,
a website of cover or anything else.
I've done competitions for instance,
for book covers related
to the four hour body.
99 designs makes great design accessible
to everyone and it makes the process so
much easier.
And I used them recently for artwork
and illustrations inside of my Tao of
Seneca set of books.
So this is a collection of stoic
writing in modern interviews and so on.
So for the Tao of Seneca, I decided to
use their one to one project service.
In this case, you invite a
specific designer to your
project, agree on a price,
and then work together
until you're satisfied.
And the artwork just blew my,
you have to check it out.
I kid you not.
And so you can check out some of the
artwork from top Seneca as well as some
artwork and logos and so on that
your fellow listeners had had
made@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash
Tim that's nine nine designs.com/tim I
really suggest you check it out.
And right now you guys can receive a
free $99 upgrade on your first project.
This gets you,
I think 130% more submission.
So people who want to work with you and
give you a first drafts of what you're
looking for.
To access your free design,
please visit 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim and click the link on the landing
page. That's 99 designs.com
forward slash. Tim,
this episode is brought to you by Peloton
and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again, but I ended up getting
a Peloton bike in the whole system.
After I saw my buddy Kevin Rose and
note of forever, some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house
a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him as a dude, you look great.
What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing
a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean
after like 75 beers and he said,
I've been doing peloton five days a week.
Now that caught my attention because Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know, I love you Kevin, but
it really peaked my curiosity.
Ended up getting a system and it's
become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to
love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually.
But peloton is an indoor cycling bike
that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You know if worry about fitting classes
into your schedule or making into a
studio with some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and
this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors
in your own living room.
You can even live streams do you a
classes taught by the world's best
instructors or find your own favorite
class on demand. And in fact,
Kevin and I rarely do live classes
and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun.
Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we
usually just use classes on demand.
I really like Matt Wilbur's and his iron,
high intensity training sessions
that are shorter, like 20 minutes.
And I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and
everyone seems to have their favorite
instructor or you can select
by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD
touchscreen performance tracking metrics.
I think that that along with
the real time leaderboard,
are the main reasons that this caught my
attention when cycling never had caught
my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention. The belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect,
so it can fit in the
living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not,
and it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer,
and it is actually special
visit one Peloton that's o,
n e p e l o t o n one peloton.com and
enter the code Tim all caps Tim at
checkout to receive $100 off accessories
with your Peloton bike purchase.
Now you might say, Matt accessories. Wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever
other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and
those are in the accessory category.
So this $100 off is a very legit,
$100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really
entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else,
or you just want to get a
fantastic gift for someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com
and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter
the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories,
including the shoes that
you will want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code temp.